impossible is not a fact that's an
opinion I had no money at a 1960
Volkswagen I worked 40 dollars a week as
a janitor to buy and pay for this is the
greatest time to be alive if you're
growing you're learning you're educating
and you're developing valuable skills
what a sore get a mentor
what's up believe nation it's seven my
one word is believed in this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today let's learn
from one of the best Tony Robbins and
some of his best life-changing advice
mentor me Tony also if you want to know
what Tony and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
unstoppable confidence check out my 2:54
confident series where every day for the
next 254 days I will send you a morning
video for free to help you build your
confidence the link to join is in the
description below the fact that human
beings our strongest drive is the need
to stay consistent with how we define
ourselves so while you're in this
passionate state that's where you make
decisions so if you want to change your
life my friends you've got to change
your physiology and you got to change
your focus
[Music]
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one change your story when something is
considered quote/unquote impossible how
do you reframe it so it becomes possible
in your mind and how much of that is
mindset well I think impossible is not a
fact it's an opinion when someone tells
me it's impossible
I always just look at anybody around me
knows that they can do this that's part
of it but if they didn't know me it's
your opinion they'll say no science
shows and I say yeah I know how many
times the science shows something's
impossible now science shows it's
possible things are impossible till
somebody does it and so I find that you
know most of your business people you
look at businesses and what does it take
to make a business grow it's not
impossible like a business grow up has
been shrinking for a long time or it's
been stuck the real problem is always
the chokehold as always the psychology
and the skills of the leader always an
80% of that as psychology and 20% as the
mechanics like if you don't know how to
read your financials and you're trying
to fly the plane of your your company I
mean come on you know if all you do is
go down and you look at profit loss and
you see what it is and you have a beer
either way you either celebrated at the
brass you know something you know you're
gonna be in trouble right but if you
have the skillsets that's one thing but
you can get any skill set at the other
psychology and anytime a business is not
growing it is not because it's
impossible it's because they aren't
innovating and they're not innovating
because they're believing it's
impossible I mean if we all know what
does it take to transform and obviously
uh people it takes three things to
create a breakthrough and anything and
your personal life in your business
anywhere you need a strategy but that's
not the first place you should look and
it's the first place all of us look me
too it's our inherent thing you want to
lose weight or how do I do it I'm gonna
grow my business how do I do it it's
it's instinctively been trained to think
that way but the problem is the how-to
is usually not that complex I'm gonna
come on seventy percent of America is
what seventy-five percent of America now
is overweight is that because it's so
complex that'll be fit and strong right
only the 1% no the answer is they hide
it from you you have to work your ass
off to not hear what it takes right and
so so you know I remember I went to this
I went to a TED Med Center and I watched
about 12 doctors won't have to know to
get up and do these stories about how we
could just get patients to take their
medications and try to figure out the
whole thing and I was just looking and
going you're all talking about strategy
you've forgotten psychology because
strategy is wonderful I'm a strategist
but my whole life figured out strategy
is we both know a strategy could save
you a decade right and doesn't the
strategy could save you you know it
could make the devastating success and
failure but most people have strategies
available or they could get them or you
could create them but the problem is you
got a story and your story is why it
isn't working and the story is I've
tried what but everything if you tried
everything you'd be fit you try
everything you'd be profitable if you
tried everything you'd be there but
people say it you know I'm big-boned
that's what I used to say I'm still
big-boned but I'm 38 pounds lighter than
I was 25 years ago and I've never gained
it back right a ball was big-boned that
was my story all the good ones are gone
that's why I'm not in a relationship or
they're gay and I'm not I am they are
whatever the story is there's always a
story and what I tell people's you know
if you can just divorce the story of
your limitation and marry the truth of
your unlimited capacity then the whole
game changes rule number two feed your
mind with greatness what do you think
was the first real breakthrough that you
had as a team that started you on your
path and how did you get there
gosh there's so many one of the first
ones I think was probably just anchoring
in when my mom and my dad I ported
fathers my mom was a powerful woman so
she kicked my poor father out whose name
I carry and he adopted me and when he
went out she decided wasn't inside so
she kicked me out too by chasing out
with a knife and I wasn't worried she's
gonna stab me or anything but I decided
this is freedom I've got to find a way
to make my life work but I had no money
at a 1960 Volkswagen I worked 40 dollars
a week as a janitor to buy and pay for
and so I had no car and no money I know
I went slept in a person's laundry room
and then I decided I've gotta figure out
what to do with I need to feed my money
because I was so depressed I was so
overwhelmed I'm missing my brother and
sister and feeling just completely out
of sorts so I I got on a bus and I
traveled 14 miles a member because I
needed money at one time and I was in
this book store and I bought this book
called the magic of believing my quad
head crystals the first real book other
than maybe thinking go rich or Emerson's
essays and I started on this journey of
saying every single day I'm gonna beat
my mind I'm not going to hope the
thoughts show up I'm gonna read
biographies I'm gonna I'm gonna find out
what makes people tick I'm gonna
understand what makes me tick and I
wanted to read a book a day but I didn't
do that click to the speed reading class
and I read seven books over seven years
and they're all personal development
human development psychology physiology
and what I tried to do is take anything
that I learned and apply it and then
when I applied it you know I was 5-1 in
my sophomore in high school I'm six
seven now I tell people differences
personal growth but sincerely I I became
mister solution because I wanted to help
everybody so I was this little fat guy
and I couldn't lose weight and I lost
weight all my buddies are like how'd you
do that I said well here's what I did
they lost weight man we all got girls
and as a young kid you know that led to
where you know if you have a problem I
was mr. solution specially if your girl
is more motivated so the breakthrough
was really understanding the power of
compressing decades in the days if
someone has spent decades of their life
and they compress it into a book and you
can read it in an hour or a few days you
have such an advantage because when you
learn by your own experience it's
painful and it's slow when you learn
about other people's experience
everybody knows in the financial world
other people's money is elaborate right
but other people's experience is more
powerful than other people's money
because you can have the money and lose
it but if you give the experience you
can change it also I think that was the
beginning for me and it set me on a
lifelong path of hunger and I never lost
my hunger rule number three constantly
improve yourself
hey can't have a standard education and
expect to have an extraordinary life
it's not gonna happen the one
breakthrough for all leaders is constant
never-ending improvement and that means
educating yourself and continuing to
develop even greater emotional mastery
because that's what affects whether you
execute enough the opportunity for self
education is there we have to change our
psychology from I'm gonna do what
everybody else does and I'm mad because
it doesn't work anymore - the reality is
this the greatest time to be alive if
you're growing you're learning you're
educating and you're developing valuable
skills so instead of complaining you
gotta say where are the skill sets
valued in the marketplace and how do I
work harder on myself than anything else
because if I become more valuable then I
will be able to give more do more and
change more when I interviewed Warren
Buffett ask the most important
investment you ever made in his life you
know what he said it was I was thinking
all the companies it done you know he
said Tony going to Dale Carnegie said
what he goes because by developing
myself that's the most important
investment those skill sets learning how
to persuade learning how to speak
learning and influence all my ideas
would've died on my lips
if I hadn't be able to influence and I
learned it from that little course the
most valuable thing ever did my life he
said rule number four learn to execute a
hit on an airplane what's the first
thing they say if we get into trouble
masks will come down oxygens there and
the first thing you got to do is put it
on your kid right know why they
literally tell you to put it on yourself
you selfish bastard what's the deal here
right but it's because we don't take
care of ourselves we can't tear them so
for leaders what I was telling this it's
you first it starts with you and it
starts with your psychology 80% of
growing a business if you look at what
the choke hold is on that business it's
always the leader and 80% of that choke
hold is the psychology 20% the mechanics
I mean people in this room know the
mechanics and strategy is beyond what
anybody on earth knows in their category
so it's really about you being in the
state where you execute it's like I
always tell people knowledge is not
power it's total BS knowledge is
potential power
execution Trump's knowledge every day of
the week and some of my life is how do
you get to yourself to execute an
execution comes from learning to put
yourself in that right state if it it
rule number five be hungry I'd say don't
come in threat of anybody that work with
the successful financial athletes people
in politics it's hunger you know you and
I both know intelligence is pretty damn
valuable tool but there are a lot of
very smart people I can't fight their
way out of the
her bag and then when you find somebody
has that Hunger the hunger that doesn't
go away that hunger to be more to do
more to give more that hunger that never
ends you know that's how you get these
people that are the best in the world at
whatever they do and so if you can I
think everybody has that hunger but for
some people it's been asleep for a long
time because they're afraid they're
afraid that I'm gonna get hungry I'm
gonna try I'm gonna fail and so it's
human nature to protect yourself from
the fear by just lowering your
expectations but one things I've learned
is you get what you tolerate you get
what you tolerate yourself you get rid
you tolerate in your life and sooner or
later we sometimes hit a point we say
not under the day another hour this is
done I'm not walking this way I'm not
talking this way I'm not living this way
I'm gonna be in this relationship
anymore I'm gonna change it and when
people do that that's the beginning of a
breakthrough rule number six discipline
your mind these thoughts that we have we
think they're our thoughts so it makes
it really hard to change them people
meditate try to not think possible show
me somebody has done that successfully
consistently the fool everybody the mind
thinks thoughts but here's the
distinction if I told you a hundred
years ago we're gonna fly the moon and
back you would call me a lunatic that's
where the term comes from people still
use it it doesn't make any sense because
a lunatic for somebody thought we gotta
move back we've done it right but if I
would have told you a hundred years ago
that there's gonna be a box in your
pocket and you're gonna pull this thing
out you're gonna hit a couple buttons
and then it's gonna capture invisible
waves that are drifting around the earth
and bring the waves in and you're gonna
see somebody on the other side of the
earth and you're gonna talk to them
you're totally nuts thoughts are those
invisible waves and when you use your
body in a certain way if I sit like this
I'm gonna channel I'm gonna tap into a
different channel those waves that if
I'm sitting like this kind of like a TV
set if I turn one channel it might be a
comedy channel I'm gonna see a lot of
laughter turn another one it's a horror
channel turn another channel it's a
romance channel this is what changes
which of those waves you touch in so if
you can start to realize that your cloth
do you think are your thoughts there's
nothing unique about your thoughts
they've been around for thousands of
years you're just tapping into them
because of what you're doing with your
body that makes you too fearful or
passion or too courageous or whatever
you're feeling
as you go in those states you get
different thoughts so what I want people
to see is that learn how to just see
those thoughts go by learn how to be
entertained by those thoughts cuz I have
crazy thoughts and but what I've got
good at is going look at that crazy
thought That's not me that's of a mind
not your mind cuz if it's you how do you
change you pretty hard but I really
truly know there's I haven't heard a
thought come out of you that's original
you call them your thoughts but they're
not you've stolen them they've been
around forever
when you see that it's easier to let go
of them and letting go of those thoughts
is one of the ways that you free
yourself and them again the more you do
it just like a muscle you get better and
better better and all of a sudden they
used to make you crazy or stressed out
or make how many things you'd be worried
about then never came to be and some
people if their life is good so they
worry about other people they're never
not worried right so it's really just a
pattern if you want wealth real wealth
is not just money it's emotion that's
like what are we really after in money
you know on money you want piece of the
paper with these pictures of deceased
notables on it you want we think money
will give you think it'll give you
freedom or security or stability or love
it won't give you a lot it'll get you
sex it won't get you love money right so
really what you're after is the emotion
and so what I want people to get is the
emotion they want down all it is is a
new habit it's learning to discipline
this mind right by realizing the main
thoughts are out there and letting them
float by and constantly coming back to
what can I love about this what can I
appreciate it's like if you can learn to
love or at least appreciate start to
enjoy the things that used to get upset
about how much freedom would you have
how much more joy to have and I know
people got billions of dollars I've
coached them who is like holy Sh
they live in scarcity all the time when
man I'll never forget he's screaming at
his wife I'm in the meat I mean I'm in
the house and he's screaming his wife
because she spent some money on a bunch
of outfits and stuff like that he's a
multi-billionaire he couldn't spend all
his money in his lifetime and then he's
totally upset at his daughters in her
20s who spent some money too and I'm
like I pulled him aside afterwards and I
said what do you do this for and what do
you do it for it he's like well it's
just it's the principle thing I said no
the principle thing is do you love these
people and do you want them to have an
abundant
life when you have you don't have one
loss but you live like you're poor you
know it's like I finally got through to
them but so many people that's why say
money doesn't change you money magnifies
who you are so you want to expand the
depth of who you are and three yourself
from suffering by just knowing it's a
pattern of thought and you can change
the pattern of all rule number seven
learn from failure failure is part of
life I mean the difference for me though
is I'm like a failure as a stepping
stone to success it's a speed bump I
know I'm gonna fail but it's not failure
if you learn something and so gosh I've
made so many mistakes I've screwed so
many things up but every time I do it
just becomes it becomes a way for me to
explain to someone else what it takes
you know it's like here's what I've done
I think I have the ability to influence
people because I talk about my failures
I talk about all the things that messed
me up but I show people that didn't let
it stop me and you don't need to stop
you and I think I think that's really
the secret matter and if everything you
touch was successful first one got a
relate to people as much oh you'll be
late and also its be total [ __ ] and
everyone know it's [ __ ] and also
you'd be bored silly I mean think about
it if you just said I want this to
happen I want this to happen you know
people don't value it they don't fight
for you know it's like you see kids
sometimes in it you know your parents
will say you're not gonna value this if
you don't work for it and your kid going
value just give it to me but it's true
you know about things we've worked the
hardest for we value the most so I think
you know the purpose of the goal is not
getting it anyway the purpose of goal
you know is what who you become will you
becomes gonna make you happier it's
gonna make you sad so I'm not looking
for an effortless approach there's no
such thing and rule number eight the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is don't give up there is another
level the only reason you keep saying
there isn't as you feel so exhausted
about where you are but life the
universe or God is just testing you
because there is another level if this
is good
giant jump to excellence Giants start
good poor to good to excellence there's
a level where all your dreams are
realized there's a level that you've
always dreamed that it is real it has
not gone away
but it takes that extra burst when you
think there's nothing left there's no
way you've tried everything ten million
times and you keep going it's almost
like God is saying if you keep hitting
this wall enough times I will see that
you will not stop that you were filled
with that level of determination faith
and courage and then the door opens and
you get to that next level but most
people don't know is the next level is
just two millimeters above and it's
called outstanding ladies and gentlemen
outstanding what's it called what's it
called what's it called
outstanding magnificent unstoppable
extraordinary not excellent it's a
different level it's a level where you
are not one of the best you are the best
you know what's amazing you only have to
be to Litton is more than everybody else
and you get everything you get the joy
the last day the father the family
the passion the economics the freedom
the spirit it's all there
what Jerry Maguire called the Quan baby
all of it and it's just to milanese
above and most excellent people give up
because they're exhausted and there's
some people go the harder I hit it the
more I hit it sooner or later
it's going down I'm not stopping and
when you do that enough it pops open
now I've got a really special bonus tip
from Tony on how to get out of your
boxed life that I think you're gonna
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three-point landing questions time to
move from just watching another video to
actually taking action in your life or
your business and if you're feeling bold
leave the answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what is
the story that you need to change number
two how will you feed your mind with
greatness and number three what will you
not give up
we're living in a society where nobody
moves anymore what do we like today how
do people get injured today they don't
get injured smashing into people playing
football thing else to get into you're
typing you know picking up a pencil oh
oh that really oh that's some people get
hurt today because we don't use
everything anymore we live in the box
think about it think about our lives
today and how different it is that may
be the way we are formed a made to run
to hide to create to procreate to raise
our children to move to form to do all
the things that made us use all of our
body today what do we do you wake up and
you have this box life you have a box
breakfast right you get your box car you
drive your box office you float up a box
elevator you don't use the stairs of
course right you go to your box office
where you type on a box talking a box
right go into a box room for meetings
right sure enough got a little box you
can type on listen to this in a music
unbox have your box lunch drive your box
home we're getting the train or subway
and another box home get home to your
box and then turn on the box type on a
box message another box I mean and maybe
go get a cylinder to change your state
maybe and most people's idea of exercise
in our society today is fill the tub
pull the plug and fight the current
but that's the world we live in today
the one one sings one song yeah the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple
that would be connect a little beacon
[Music]
if you want more tony robbins check out
the eight hours of motivation we did on
him the video link is right there next
to me i think you'll enjoy it continue
to believe and i'll see you there i'm
very excited about the session because
one of the biggest challenges for
people's everybody wants a better
quality of life
everybody wants life to be greater